[Music]
as the warrior slept a snake coiled
around his face instead of a threat his
wife saw an omen a fearsome power that
would lead her husband to either glory
or doom for now however he was only a
slave one of millions taken from the
territories conquered by Rome to work
the mines till the fields or fight for
the crowds entertainment a nomadic
Thracian from what is now Bulgaria he
had served in the Roman army but was
imprisoned for desertion
his name was spartacus spartacus had
been brought to Capua by Batiatus a
lanista or trainer of gladiators and
life at the ludus or gladiator school
was unforgiving new recruits were forced
to swear an oath to be burned to be
bound to be beaten and to be killed by
the sword and to obey their masters will
without question but even harsh
discipline couldn't break Spartacus's
spirit in 73 BCE Spartacus led 73 other
slaves to seize knives and skewers from
the kitchen and fight their way out
hijacking a wagon of gladiator equipment
along the way they were done fighting
for others
now they fought for their freedom
when the news reached Rome the Senate
was too busy with Wars in Spain and the
Pontic Empire to worry about some unruly
slaves unconcerned prior Claudius Glaber
took an army of 3,000 men to the rebels
refuge at Mount Vesuvius and blocked off
the only passage up the mountain all
that remained was to wait and starve
them out or so he thought in the dead of
night the rebels lowered themselves down
the cliffside on ropes made from vines
and flanked Labour's unguarded camp thus
began the legend of Rome's defiant
gladiator as news of the rebellion
spread its ranks swelled with escaped
slaves deserting soldiers and hungry
peasants many were untrained but
Spartacus's clever tactics transformed
them into an effective guerrilla force a
second Roman expedition led by prior
Varinius was ambushed while the officer
bathed to elude the remaining Roman
forces the rebels used their enemy's
corpses as decoy guards stealing
Varinius his own horse to aid their
escape thanks to his inspiring victories
and policy of distributing spoils
equally Spartacus continued attracting
followers and gained control of villages
where new weapons could be forged
the Romans soon realized they were no
longer facing ragtag fugitives and in
the spring of 72 BCE the Senate
retaliated with the full force of two
legions the rebels left victorious but
many lives were lost in the battle
including Spartacus as lieutenant Crixus
to honor him Spartacus held funeral
games forcing his Roman prisoners to
play the role his fellow rebels had once
endured by the end of 72 BCE Spartacus's
army was a massive force of roughly
120,000 members but those numbers proved
difficult to manage with the path to the
Alps clear
Spartacus wanted to march beyond Rome's
borders where his followers would be
free but his vast army had grown
brash many wanted to continue pillaging
while others dreamed of marching on Rome
itself in the end the rebel army turned
south forgoing what would be their last
chance at freedom meanwhile Marcus
Licinius Crassus had assumed control of
the war as Rome's wealthiest citizen he
pursued Spartacus with eight new legions
eventually trapping the rebels in the
toe of Italy after failed attempts to
build rafts and a stinging betrayal by
local pirates the rebels made a
desperate run to break through Crassus
lines but it was no use
Roman reinforcements were returning from
the Pontic wars and the rebels ranks and
spirits were broken in 71 BCE they made
their last stand
Spartacus nearly managed to reach
Crassus before being cut down by
Centurions his army was destroyed and
6,000 captives were crucified along the
Appian Way a haunting demonstration of
Roman authority Crassus won the war but
it is not his legacy which echoes
through the centuries thousands of years
later the name of the slave who made the
world's mightiest Empire tremble has
become synonymous with freedom and the
courage to fight for it
find out more about life in ancient Rome
with this playlist
[Music]